This is a really fast,
quickly growing movement among millennials.
Something like 10% identify as a third gender.
So that's a lot of people and I would be totally on board with people
identifying however they want.
If it didn't also include things like medical interventions,
like double mastectomies, taking testosterone, testosterone, a lot of cases.
And in a lot of the cases,
I think these are just young gay people who are struggling with that.
Do you think it's starting the sort of hysterical nature of this,
of what you just described?
Like you have to be attracted to me if this and all of those things,
do you think it's starting to backfire on them? Because I think most people,
even, even conservatives that sort of, as you alluded to earlier, they don't,
they don't sort of love talking about these topics.
I don't know a lot of conservatives that don't want trans people.
I don't know any conservatives actually that don't want trans people to be
treated equally under the law or something or something like that.
But I do sense that there's a real backlash now where the movement has gone so
far that people are just like, you know what, forget this whole thing.
Like the whole thing is evil. And that's what I'm worried about because when,
when we group these letters together, um, I can,
I can sort of understand the people that are frustrated like that.
I could see that what we're really concerns me is where we are going to be
going,
what the next step is going to be in terms of what the outcome is going to be.
And so we're seeing also this growing trend of nonbinary people identifying as
nonbinary. And again, that can be for some people,
a way of coping with the fact that they are gay or lesbian,
and they are not yet able to accept that about themselves or because it is
easier to not identify as gay in society because there is still homophobia.
And so again.
What non-binary is just for, for someone that might not know.
Yeah. So it's people who identify as a third gender.
So they may say they're both genders or neither. And so non binary,
gender fluid, gender neutral, gender,
even though is considered by some peoples to be a slur against gay people.
I don't tend to like to use the word. Um, so yeah,
so this is a really fast,
quickly growing movement among millennials.
Something like 10% identify as a third gender.
So that's a lot of people and I would be totally on board with people
identifying however they want.
If it didn't also include things like medical interventions,
like double mastectomies taking testosterone's testosterone, a lot of cases.
And in a lot of the cases,
I think these are just young gay people who are struggling with that
and we should offer them support instead of having them undergo these
interventions.
Right? So that's what I think is so interesting about this,
because I think the average person wants most people to live and let live.
And however you identify, that's fine.
As long as you're not forcing someone to do something, I think what,
what happens then is this next version where it's like, you can be,
you can say you're non and if you feel that way, then so be it.
But what happens is then they won't let you accept biology.
So now it seems like this is now in direct conflict with biology.
And I think a lot of people are sort of, they're like, no,
that's the last line here that we're, we're just not going to give on you.
Do you think that's fair to say.
Right? And again, I like you.
I have no issue with people how they want to identify. Just don't tell me that.
That's what the scientific research shows,
because when you start denying science that doesn't help anyone and the truth is
eventually going to come out. So with regards to gender,
gender is binary because for 99% of us, our gender is our biological sex.
Of course there are intersex people and there are trans people for whom this
doesn't necessarily apply,
but that's not to say that gender is a spectrum or that it's however you
want it. You don't, you don't choose your gender. You know,
this is what they're teaching an education now that,
that people choose their gender.
And I think it's really harmful to put all this misinformation out there,
especially in the case of someone who is identifying this way,
for reasons that may come from, you know, their own internal struggles,
maybe they have other mental health issues. And they're not,
we're not being able to talk about that.
I think if we could have the conversation and someone could say, yes,
I've considered all these things,
but I still feel I would like to have a double mastectomy.
And that would be better for me,
even though a lot of these individuals are really young when they're doing this,
then I wouldn't have so much of a problem,
but we can't even have the conversation. If you've been trying to bring it up,
it's considered hateful even to say that there are two genders is considered
transphobic now.
Right? So what, so, all right.
Some people watching this are going to clip it and show say that you're
transphobic and I'm a self hating gay and all, all the usual stuff.
So to counter that, and you write about this in the book, it,
can you just sort of give me the, the roadmap, if there was a young person,
six years old, that really felt that, you know, they were,
they were physically a boy, but they identified as a girl.
What do you think a healthy roadmap would be as opposed to the unhealthy
roadmap that you're talking about?
That's just transitioning them at such a younger age.
I would say to the parents, especially just to love your child unconditionally,
it doesn't matter what toys they want to play with, what they want to dress,
how they want to dress, who their friends are, anything like that. Let,
if this little boy wants to wear makeup and dresses and play with his
girlfriends, and that should be totally fine. And conversely,
if you have a little boy who is male, typical, I think that's also fine.
I think among, especially woke parents,
they don't want their children to be gender typical nowadays,
which is just so bizarre. So it's,
it's like the inverse of what it used to be that parents didn't want their kids
playing with gender atypical toys,
because they're afraid their kids are gonna grow up to be gay.
And now it's that they don't want them playing with gender typical toys because
they think that's going to limit their growth as an adult. So yeah,
just leave him alone. And if he says he wants to be the opposite sex,
see how he feels up your body.
Right. So then what, what is, what does that look like? So now, okay,
so the child, they, they love them. They,
they let them play with whatever they want, be friends with whatever,
whoever they want to wear, whatever they want, et cetera. Now,
now puberty comes along then, then where are you at?
Well, what would normally happen? Saving?
What's been documented in the research.
Literature is children who are gender dysphoric.
Once they start having crushes on their peers,
once they start growing into their bodies, a lot of them realize, Oh,
this is actually pretty great. I like my body. And I'm happy.
The ones who remain dysphoric and persist,
I would recommend seeing a mental health professional, or even,
even prior to that point, if,
if the child's gender dysphoria is quite severe and debilitating.
The issue though, is that nowadays the vast,
vast majority of mental health professionals who work with gender dysphoric
children and even gender dysphoric adults are,
I don't want to say that they're compromised,
but definitely ideologies playing a huge role in terms of how they practice,
because they cannot by law say anything other
than, yes, if you want to transition,
I'll help you I'll help to facilitate this because they're going to be accused
then of commit of practicing conversion therapy.
Even though conversion therapy for gender identity does not exist.
There there's a difference between conversion therapy for sexual orientation,
which is, was we talked about last time is not effective. It should not be done.
There's no such thing as conversion therapy for a gender identity because young
children who identify as the opposite sex again,
their gender is I don't use the word fluid,
but it's more flexible because they haven't fully developed yet.
So with development, they're more likely to feel differently.
Right. All right. So wait, just to completely clear that up.
And we did go into the first part or the second part, uh, last time.
So gender or conversion therapy for gay people, meaning to take, uh,
a young gay boy and to do whatever version of conversion therapy there is.
Uh, there's just no evidence that, that actually works.
What you're saying here is if a,
if a therapist was dealing with a young person who identified as the other
gender, that in essence,
they sort of have to go with it because what,
what is it that they would lose their license or, or is there,
cause it's not conversion at that point at some level, right? Like what, what,
what, or, or you think it's just the pressure of being a therapist that they'll,
they'll be ostracized.
It's the climate it's that other professionals will ostracize them.
It's because they do run the risk of then losing their license because
organizations will come after them and say,
you are not practicing according to what the standards are supposed to be,
that you also have activists coming after them trying to ruin their reputation
and their livelihood.
And so what has happened is I know colleagues who have told me that anyone who
does not feel right about this, they are leaving the field.
They will not see patients with gender dysphoria period because they just,
they don't feel right. And they can't do their job properly.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about academia,
instead of nonstop, yelling out our academia playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist they're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.